the husband is very important for you it
take time but I still hope before 30
years all around the world women face
pressure from society and even their own
families to live a certain way and fit
specific expectations whether it's
marriage or career related it seems
everyone has a thought on how we ought
to live we partnered with us k2 a global
skin care brand that continues to
empower women to take control and shape
their own destiny as part of their
global change destiny campaign together
we explore the pressures women feel to
conform to a certain timeline by
inviting mothers and daughters to
discuss these very real issues in their
own lives enjoy the episode and be sure
to stick around to the end for more info
to share
hi everyone I'm dr. jewel
I'm Africa's mom mama 5 and I'm an
educator my name is Ann Marie I have
five children and I'm a housewife my
name is Cindy I have two daughters
why is Casandra here and I'm a housewife
I'm Chelsea
I am I travel blogger and I teacher
my name is Africa I am a songwriter and
a dancer my name is Cassandra
I am a social-media influencer dancer
and gamer I I do believe that marriage
is an old-fashioned institution that
doesn't mean that you know it's not
important or that it's not relevant but
I feel like it is dated and it is you
know transforming into something
different I would definitely feel like
the reasons for marriage
are much different now than it was
before I don't believe that it is a
requirement in life as much for me it's
like the history of marriage started
with women literally being sold as if
they are property and like that's
archaic you know and I just don't agree
with that as a concept but at the same
time you know I'm a romantic and I
believe in love and I believe that if
you love someone you should be allowed
to marry them if that's what you want my
husband and I when we got married we
just loved each other and very naturally
so we don't have any other concern about
do we have enough money or do we have
any other things with just a very pure
yeah
personally I love I love you mom but I
would not do what you did I would not do
it if I'm correct
you got married at 25 and I believe he
dated dad for six months yes right
before that marriage I I personally
fully believe that before marriage you
should be living with that person cuz
living with someone I feel like it's
different than just dating them I don't
know
that whole we're not gonna live together
for two years tomorrow and I'll just be
sitting here with this rent uh uh like
there's some maturities in marriage if
you want me you got to put up the cost
to pay the boss like thank you girl
ladies think that you're gonna move in
with your spouse right and then that
first year's gonna be bliss if it's the
right one that's not the case so you
move in with someone six month oh we're
not compatible you might have been if
you're married you're committed to work
into your life together I mean I don't
Chelsea I don't know if you're living
are you living with your boyfriend I I
am and that and that's something that I
guess for me is a little bit of a
frustration because we've been together
for almost four years I can tell that
you know my siblings that are married
and have like a kid on the way or my
friends that have kids and are married
it's their lives and their relationships
are taking more seriously the - we are
just as committed you know we're
monogamous we care about each other it's
a partnership and I just get frustrated
that because we're not married that
means that we're just dating it's like
frivolous you know what I mean which
it's not my mom's expectations and goals
for me she wants me to get married and
have kids because she thinks that will
make me feel fulfilled and happy right
now I live with my long-term boyfriend
we don't know if we will ever get
married or have children we're focusing
on our careers my my passion is
traveling and seeing new cultures that's
what makes me happy and brings me joy
and that's what I'm focusing on right
now
my parents are they're kind of
wishy-washy they they respect a little
bit of my my wanting to delay my
marriage but on my boyfriend's side of
things his mom you know we've been
living together for a long time and she
didn't really know about it I think she
kind of did but she wasn't gonna think
about it she's been calling my boyfriend
and every time she's like okay you need
to propose you need to get married
you're living together it's time it's
happening I recently separated from my
boyfriend
and my dad freaked out he literally was
texting me like he doesn't do drugs he
doesn't gamble he doesn't drink he
doesn't womanize he works hard like what
more do you want I didn't know you have
the pressure I feel bad the husband is
very important for you it take time to
know this person so I really don't want
to give you any pressure but I still
hope before 30 years my mom was the
opposite from the time I was really
little she was working full-time she was
never available I had a friend who had
go to her house and her mom was there
all cute with their cookies right and
it's like I want that life and it was
always getting married late and and you
better continue working in a
high-powered job and pay your bills
because if your husband leaves you I
guess I just bounced and just did the
absolute opposite you know I did get my
degree but then I was married at 23 I
think it's difficult because I think
were one of the first generations of
when like divorce was common like I
remember growing up in elementary school
it would be like 75% of the class had
parents that were divorced or split up
so I think we're a lot more you know
nervous we have a lot more trepidation
we really want to be sure I mean I get
everything that you guys are saying and
I understand it I know what it's like to
be in a marriage when you or yourself
are not fulfilled and I wouldn't I
wouldn't wish that on anybody
the only challenge if you're constantly
like okay well this is great and this
was two years and the next one would be
great and that was three years when do
you say okay right here is where I'm
going to build but at the same time I
mean again we're not saying date a
hundred people I know for me personally
whenever I'm actually entering it into
any relationship I do believe this is
gonna be the last one again you don't
know people a hundred percent until
you've dated them until you've taken
that time time can it be rushed my
current plan for the future is to
establish my career I'm highly
interested in a professional career in
songwriting I don't have any plans for
marriage or kids being who I want to be
you know living where I want to live all
those things are important for me right
now by the time I was her age had three
kids and I was a mom I think one my hood
is very powerful we literally give life
to the world
[Music]
have you ever noticed that if I don't
know but I have definitely asked a
significant other here there or maybe
even just a guy friend like hey do you
want kids you know and they're also like
taken aback that before whoa and for
women I feel like it's almost expected
like you should have a plan that's the
perception we're given especially as
women is like you need to be married in
order to be happy you need to have kids
in order to be happy or like for your
life to mean anything it's just not true
I have an aunt who is unmarried and did
not have kids and she is a long-term
partner that she lives with and they
travel all the time they of can't afford
to do what they want and they're happy
and they're living a good life I made
the conscious decision about three
months ago maybe to get like tubal
ligation and basically like tubes tied
because I I don't know I'm just tired of
this whole back-and-forth like oh you
got to take this birth control or
whatever and like a lot of them don't
work for me when I talk to the doctors
of course it's their job to like ask you
all these questions are you sure bah bah
bah and like but it's so interesting
they make you sign the paper but they
make you wait 30 days
again just in case you change your mind
that's just a decision I made personally
because it's just not what I want I just
don't want kids I never have I think
it's so funny because I think you guys
are like breaking their hearts because
Africa when you said that you get did
you get the tubal ligation oh yeah okay
we did it I'm like getting teary yeah
she was over there honey like yeah I
don't know why I'm sorry but it's like
it's what do you know when you're 25 I'm
26 26 I'm just saying I have friends who
made it to like 39 or 40 never wanted
kids and then changed their mind I think
it's one of the most amazing things
about being a woman is actually carrying
a life inside you you know and and I
know you disagree with me how do you
young people feel when you hear her
saying she wants to be like Asian I was
really surprised by that I support you
absolutely but that's definitely not
what I would want for myself it's
something I wouldn't treat because I'm
still very uncertain it changes everyday
so for you to have the courage to do it
I believe that you are all-knowing and
that you really believe in it you know
we have five kids my middle daughter is
like the opposite of me she's in an
all-male business high-powered job and
then I talked to her about kids and
having you know having a family getting
married and and she blows me off I
really tried to hold back from being
like pushing my opinions on people but I
do you know my daughter I'm like you
really need to have at least one child
just to experience it well I didn't know
if you did it or not cuz I just had to
let it just at the end of the day and
sure buddy it's your decision I would
never say you have to have a child it
was very disappointing and hurtful for
me though I feel that having children
and bringing life is like the most
natural thing like so for me and my mom
had me really young and I watched her
give up everything you know to be a
mother and to raise me and she was a
single mom for a while in a selfish way
part of me is like I don't know
if I can do that to the level that she
did and I feel bad because I you know
part of me is like do I owe her a
grandchild because of what she did for
me you know what I mean do I owe her do
I heard that if I think if you have a
marriage and have a children one day of
you really sick
and parents are not here and someone can
take care of you I agree but I feel like
there's so much more that I need to
learn and I'm just now learning like
it's scaring me how some people that I
know who are getting married you know
don't know how to do their taxes and
everything's just kind of taken care of
and that that can be a nice thing but
for me I very much want to be able to
take care of myself I also know myself
and I'm a very social person if I am on
my deathbed with whatever cancer it may
be at that point
I feel like I would have no trouble
having people who care about me
surrounding me I can marry when I was 25
even though she has a lot of friends I
think the family is the most important I
would love to have children in the
future
I just don't know if that's like my top
priority right now the personal goal of
mine to build my Chinese lion dance team
and to pursue the endeavors that I've
started
[Music]
it's embarrassing to admit but it's just
I just feel like you know I'm not like
my husband and the way we've set up our
family has worked for us you know what
I'm okay bringing making him dinner
every night I'm okay for him you know
paying the bills and you know I was
really okay having children and you know
I think children do better when a mom is
at home and she takes on that
traditional role don't hate it's just
it's not a popular choice right it's not
a popular thought but I think it's a
spectrum right because I definitely
believe in letting a man be a man but he
can cook too
who really has the right to tell
somebody this is what real womanhood is
or this is what real manhood is somebody
could say you know I wasn't a good mom
for taking my kids down to the
university twice a week because I needed
to finish my masters but I did that so
that I could be a better mom to them my
boyfriend and I have a pretty
interesting situation he's he's from a
pretty traditional family but I'm
crazy-crazy independent I'm I'm like the
the financier of a lot of the
relationship and a lot of times he cooks
and we have that flipped but we've made
it work I'm on this whole thing right
now where I separated from my boyfriend
because I was like I need to live on my
own for a while because I found myself
changing within the relationship and
losing my independence to the point
where I felt like I couldn't do things
when we first got married we fell into
those roles you know and so my husband
hasn't cooked dinner for us through like
28 years I'm not up on our finances he
pays all the bills I've given all that
over to him out of you know in my early
20s it's worked for us so I don't know
if it's a bad thing
you know what if he wasn't
supportive I probably couldn't be that
kind of why or couldn't do that right
but I did struggle with guilt a little
bit that I've kind of given that over to
my husband all this time you know and
I've kind of gotten to a safe place but
me that maybe that's gonna change I got
married at 23 a year and half later I
was pregnant with my first two five I
love having a big family there's this
built-in community and support for one
another my middle daughter this
beautiful girl and she's so independent
and all over the place and traveling all
over by herself I want her to be safe I
want her to be happy I'd love for her to
get married
she met a wonderful man and she seems
really happy I am so scared to display
everything that I say I'm so scared of
disappointing you mom and dad oh I
already know I've disappointed that I
knew you were very hard
you really work very hard so I think you
have the parent for you our dream I
think for me I've risked so much I want
my kids to know that risk is okay that a
calculated risk is okay and so I can't
feel because I know they're looking at
me and if they have any dreams in their
hearts and I give up our mind how can I
ever say something to them you know me
personally I guess I don't really think
about it because both of my parents are
probably the best role models for like
you do what you want to do you know like
my dad he loved trucks and trains since
he was a kid and so I became a truck
driver
my mom she discovered West African dance
when she was 18 and so that's what she
did she became a dancer and then people
maybe thought they were crazy but they
did it anyway
of course I am
little scared of disappointing my mom
but I think overall I think I think
she's proud and she knows you know that
everything that I do is with good intent
and I think if I choose not to get
married to have kids I think that'll be
another painful thing for her but she'll
understand because she loves me and she
knows I'm doing what's best for me I
think there is a part of Rachel my
middle daughter that I think no she
doesn't want to disappoint me she was
engaged for a long time to it to a guy
she met when she was 18 and it wasn't
right she wasn't happy she wasn't
glowing she was so worried about
disappointing me because I had already
paid for the venue that she was gonna go
through with the wedding so I took her
for a walk on the beach and I said
Rachel I don't care you could be had the
flowers in hand in the white dress ready
to walk down the aisle and you could say
mommy take me away and I would put you
in the car and you wouldn't have to face
anything at all
I think his mom's we just want the best
for you guys we just want you to be
fulfilled and happy and she doesn't want
you to have any regrets in life she
doesn't want you to look back when
you're our age and go damn I wish I had
done it differently or I wish I had made
this decision you know make sure that
you're doing there what's gonna be right
for you not just now but for you know 20
years from now you know as a mom we
really love you guys and no matter what
you do we love you period
it's not about these rigid rules and
regulations and you must this and the
timeline and the ticking clock this
about I love you no matter what it's
it's a different world now and so we
can't expect you to be the same women
that are this that fall into the same
rules that maybe I did when I was 22
it's opened my mind so I'm very grateful
for that so thank you and it's good to
hear from people's perspective people
who have gone the more traditional route
of getting married and having kids
to see you fulfilled that's really great
I think today is nice too to have an
open and honest communication with with
some other mothers that I think my mom
would agree with so it was really nice
to maybe hear the words that she would
want to say to me but she doesn't feel
right saying to me and I really
appreciated hearing that and it's helped
me I don't know maybe rethink some
things I I definitely know that
sometimes when my parents tell me
something I kind of blow it off it's not
that they don't ever get it but it's
just we come from two completely
different times you know the world is
changing we're all changing we're always
changing probably I get Concentra a lot
of pressure I think so yeah I didn't do
that on purpose I want to communicate
with you more I hope to know anything in
your deep your mind and you can ask me
anything you want to from now on okay
thanks thank you I want I just want to
see you're happy I would want to see her
just continue to know that those things
that are in her heart our valley are
important and that the world meets them
and needs her the challenges that young
women have today are very different when
I was younger there was you know a few
paths that I could take but now you know
women can do anything you know me not
being a mom myself it's hard for me to
realize the reasoning behind my mom's
opinions I know she only has my best
interests in mind and that's what she
wants despite the generation time gap at
the end of the day we all have the same
goals we all want to feel fulfilled and
live a happy life
we're just taking different paths to get
there
[Laughter]
thank you so much everyone for watching
this is a topic that's really close to
our hearts and it was an absolute
privilege to have all these women come
in and open their lives up to us and be
a part of this discussion absolutely and
we want to send a huge shout out to sk2
thank you so much they made this video
possible and they were super supportive
so we highly recommend that you guys
check out hashtag timelines it's this
awesome Doki series that sk2 did with
Katie Couric explores the pressures put
on women around the world by like
society and their families but also
shows amazing stories of women who are
following their dreams and creating
their own destiny and we hope that you
guys do the same our team here at
Jubilee loved this series and we know
that our audience will too until next
time guys yeah
you